en el vídeo de repaso de la estructura
de las proteínas hablamos acerca de los
diferentes niveles de la estructura de
las proteínas y empezamos con la
estructura primaria y todo esto es
simplemente un rápido repaso pero la
estructura primaria es simplemente el
orden de los aminoácidos y después de
eso nos pusimos a pensar en cómo
empiezan a tomar forma en las proteínas
y empezamos a hablar acerca de la
estructura secundaria y la estructura
secundaria se debe a las interacciones
del esqueleto proteico porque hay del
esqueleto de los polipéptidos que forman
a la proteína y eso lo vimos con un poco
más de detalle por aquí hablamos acerca
de las hojas plegadas beta por aquí
tenemos dos esqueletos proteicos que
además están orientados en la misma
dirección nitrógeno carbono alfa carbono
del grupo- carbón hilo nitrógeno y
carbono alfa carbono del grupo- carbón
hilo y tengo por aquí las cadenas
laterales
a las cuales las representamos
simplemente como grupo seres y también
vimos que se forman puentes de hidrógeno
entre los dos esqueletos así es que esta
es la hoja plegada beta paralela o si
los dos esqueletos están orientados en
sentidos contrarios entonces tenemos la
hoja plegada beta anti paralela ok
porque aquí la dirección del esqueleto
es nitrógeno carbono alfacar bono del
grupo carbón y lo en este esqueleto y en
este otro tenemos nitrógeno carbono del
grupo carbon hilo y después carbono alfa
entonces están orientados en sentidos
contrarios así es que es una hoja
plegada beta anti paralela y también se
pueden formar estos puentes de hidrógeno
o también podemos tener una estructura
de hélice alfa en donde tenemos puentes
de hidrógeno entre los distintos niveles
de la hélice
y finalmente llegamos a la estructura
terciaria y la estructura terciaria
ahora si se trata de las interacciones
entre las cadenas laterales y ahora si
nos ponemos a pensar en cómo estos
grupos se re afectan a la estructura de
la proteína y para ayudarnos a pensar un
poco más en esto dibuje unas cosas por
aquí abajo y bueno nos podemos imaginar
solo para que sea más simple que esta
curva naranja de aquí es el esqueleto de
nuestro polipéptido
solo como una especie de repaso rápido
podemos ponernos a pensar acerca de la
estructura primaria cuál sería la
estructura primaria de este polipéptido
aunque hay digamos que por aquí tenemos
este aminoácido y después tengo este
otro aminoácido y luego tengo este otro
aminoácido y la secuencia de estos
aminoácidos
esta es la estructura primaria así es
que la secuencia la secuencia es la
estructura primaria y después cuando
estamos viendo estas interacciones entre
el esqueleto proteico esa es la
estructura secundaria y aquí seguramente
tenemos una hoja plegada beta anti
paralela ok por aquí estos son puentes
de hidrógeno justo aquí entre estos dos
esqueletos aunque no dibuje por aquí ni
una sola cadena lateral y por acá lo que
tenemos es una hélice alfa donde otra
vez tenemos estos puentes de hidrógeno
entre los distintos niveles
de la hélice pero ahora sí ya vamos a
hablar acerca de la estructura terciaria
que se trata de cómo interactúan las
cadenas laterales por aquí tenemos un
ejemplo de estructura terciaria aquí
dibujé un montón de cadenas laterales
todas estas son aminoácidos valina
aunque no dibuje la parte del esqueleto
proteico bucay pero el esqueleto está
por aquí obviamente nada de esto está en
una escala real pero las cadenas
laterales de la balín a los grupos seres
del havalina son puros hidrocarburos los
cuales son hidrofóbicos y una
interacción que te vas a encontrar muy
comúnmente en estas cadenas laterales
hidrofóbicas es que estas cadenas
hidrofóbicas no les gusta el contacto
con el agua y por lo tanto si tu
proteína está en una solución acuosa no
les va a gustar estar expuestas al agua
por lo cual seguramente se van a
aglomerar en el centro
soy claro que puede afectar la forma en
la que se dobla la cadena poli peptídica
y afecta la forma de la proteína ok
estas cadenas laterales y aquí pueden
ser hidrofóbicas y se aglomeran huyendo
del agua estoy dibujando todo esto en la
segunda dimensión pero por supuesto las
proteínas están en la tercera dimensión
lo cual hace que su estructura sea
todavía más interesante y en ocasiones
difícil de entender o procesar por
completo por otro lado también podríamos
tener el aminoácido serín que tiene un
grupo hidroxilo por aquí y como esto es
polar porque el oxígeno es más electro
negativo que el hidrógeno ok entonces el
oxígeno tiene una carga parcial negativa
y el hidrógeno tiene una carga parcial
positiva como el grupo hidroxilo es
polar eso permite que esta parte de la
cadena sea un poco más hidrofílica así
es que se puede encontrar por afuera de
la proteína en contacto con la solución
acuosa
o incluso también podría formar algunos
puentes de hidrógeno con alguna otra
cadena lateral así es que digamos que la
cadena sigue por aquí y por cierto para
nada estoy dibujando esto a escala por
ejemplo aquí estoy exagerando por mucho
el tamaño de las cadenas laterales pero
digamos que de pura casualidad tenemos
por aquí otra cadena lateral que tiene
un montón de cosas de hecho voy a poner
tres puntitos por aquí que de no tener
un montón de cosas y después tenga un
oxígeno que está enlazado con algún otro
hidrógeno y entonces tal vez se puede
formar por aquí algún puente de
hidrógeno y eso también ayudaría a
mantener esta estructura por otro lado
también podemos tener cadenas laterales
que sean iónicas
podemos tener cadenas que tengan una
carga formal por ejemplo digamos que
aquí tenemos una cadena lateral
que tiene una carga positiva y ahora
digamos que nuestro esqueleto poli
peptídica vueltas de esta forma y por
aquí podemos tener alguna otra cadena
lateral que tenga una carga negativa y
entonces éstas se van a sentir atraídas
mutuamente y vamos a tener un enlace
iónico de hecho hasta podemos tener
enlaces covalentes entre las cadenas
laterales por aquí tenemos uno de esos
enlaces covalentes que se encuentran muy
comúnmente entre dos aminoácidos
cisteína porque estas dos cisternas
tienen un átomo de azufre a ver vamos a
separar a una de las cisternas aquí
tenemos un nitrógeno el carbono alfa y
el carbono del grupo carbón y lo
entonces esta es una cisteína que bueno
en realidad la cisteína aquí este azufre
tiene un enlace covalente con un
hidrógeno pero bajo circunstancias
adecuadas pueden formar un enlace
covalente con otro azufre
y en este caso es el azufre de la cadena
lateral de otra cisteína y este de aquí
se llama enlace de sulfuro en la sed y
sulfuro así es que nos podríamos
imaginar que aquí tenemos una cisterna y
aquí también podemos tener otra cisterna
y sus dos cadenas laterales pueden
formar un enlace de sulfuro y este
enlace covalente de sulfuro ayuda a que
estas dos se mantengan juntas podríamos
hasta decir que las están grabando en
fin espero que esto te ayude a
comprender la cantidad de interacciones
que suceden que influencian la forma y
la estructura de cualquier proteína y
finalmente nos vamos a regresar por acá
porque también tenemos la estructura
cuaternaria que se trata de cómo ponemos
varios polipéptidos juntos y toda esta
serie de vídeos se tratan de que
observes que aunque tengamos la
secuencia de aminoácidos no sabemos qué
forma o qué interacciones va a tener esa
proteína pero
y toda esa cantidad de diferentes formas
e interacciones que pueden tener las
proteínas eso es lo que hace que las
proteínas sean complejas que sean
hermosas y tengan esa increíble
habilidad de realizar todas estas
funciones como catalizar reacciones
funcionando como enzimas o ser señales
en forma de hormonas o hasta proveer la
integridad estructural de una célula y
también pueden tener muchas otras
funciones por ejemplo aquí en el caso de
la hemoglobina ayudan a transportar el
oxígeno así es que esto de la estructura
de las proteínas es un área enorme de
investigación porque incluso aunque
sepas cuál es la secuencia de
aminoácidos no sabemos cuál es la forma
de esa proteína y si supiéramos cuál es
la forma basándonos en esa forma cómo
podemos utilizarlo para pensar en cómo
manipular a esa proteína en distintas
formas o cualquier otra cosa que se nos
ocurra el si es que es un campo de
investigación realmente fascinante